time to play a little fill in the blanks
now that we're eight weeks into the 2019
regular season and let's begin with this
after those first eight weeks
blank has changed my opinion of him
the most oh that this is this is good
okay i just want to give a shout out to
dalvin cook okay this is not my pick but
i just want to say he's one guy okay i
knew he was talented but he's changed my
opinion a lot but i think the guy that
i'm gonna go with here more than anybody
daniel jones uh daniel jones i mean
through eight weeks you know and i know
he didn't start the season and what's he
played now five six games i don't really
know don't care it's somewhere in that
range but he's played really well and he
showed me that he was worthy of the
sixth pick of the draft um has he made a
few dumb rookie mistakes and things like
that sure yes he has but let's not
forget it's not like he's got like this
plethora of talent around him right now
either i mean he's played some games at
quarterback where you know i don't even
know some of the receivers he's throwing
to all right so uh there he was last
week again matching touchdown passes
with matthew stafford through four
touchdown passes in a game on the road
nobody talks about it because the giants
aren't very good right now but i think
from where i came to the draft then oh
pre-season and the way he took over that
first start in the tampa bay buccaneers
i got to give daniel jones the guy that
has uh changed my opinion the most of
him through the first half of the season
see should i go positive here or should
i go negative and balance out you
praising both dalvin cook gratuitously
and then getting to the point and i just
got to give some honorable mentions it's
such a it's these are good good
questions so i just want to make sure we
include a few other guys but go ahead
negative nancy
yeah i i i'm going to continue something
that we discussed on monday we discussed
it yesterday and
and and i need to take responsibility
for this because when the 2018 season
ended
i was one of the people saying
wait a minute we see what the trend is
in the nfl toward the hiring of
offensive minded coaches
and if the cleveland browns were to hire
somebody other than freddie kitchens to
be their head coach and keep freddie
kitchens as the offensive coordinator
and he continues to do good work with
baker mayfield they're going to lose
freddie kitchens after the year because
somebody's going to snatch him up to be
the head coach sure so why not just make
him their head coach right i was all in
for that yeah but after eight weeks
i gotta say freddy kitchens all due
respect i.e here comes the insult he was
not prepared and still is not prepared
to be an nfl head coach and the question
is chris how much time will they give
him to learn the job on the fly and at
what point do we go from unprepared to
unfit and look that's a fair assessment
he could be the next norv turner wade
phillips guy who's a great coordinator
but can't be an effective head coach and
he's such a great coordinator he keeps
getting chances to be a head coach and
failing at it and going back to being a
great coordinator yeah but i thought
freddie kitchen b would be able to pull
it off and based upon
and the thing for me chris that really
was alarming after all the years i've
been following football covering
football
this whole idea of taking an intentional
penalty on fourth and 11th because you
don't want to use a timeout when you're
down 17 so you'd rather try to convert a
fourth and 16. that's incomprehensible
to me
and uh and then he admitted on monday
that he didn't bother to tell anyone
that he was planning to go for it no
matter what which caused the punt team
to go out on the field which sparked
this whole incident but i just think
he's over his skis and i didn't think it
was going to be this way and i have to
be honest with that opinion yeah okay i
i get you i mean i don't think you're
wrong in your opinion i don't think it's
like egregiously mean by you or anything
like that yeah you know i still do have
faith in the guy i really do i think a
lot's been thrusted on him you've made
you know these comments on pro football
talk.com and things like this where you
know here is a guy that went from like
position coach to thrusted into
offensive coordinator which you know i
don't know if he was even really ready
to do that quite yet and now he's the
head coach usually there's a process for
guys where they get to like oh i'm an
offensive coordinator for two or three
years and things have been good and they
start to go i'm getting dabbles for
being a head coach and you start to go
okay how am i going to manage games and
you know what do i do in this situation
i don't know if freddie kitchen's ever
really got that you know a little grace
period to kind of figure those type of
things out and he is learning on the fly
and he's got a young team and they got
talent and they're learning how to win
and he's learning how to coach and i get
everything you said i still think the
guy is a good coach but yeah i don't
know if he's he's certainly not handling
all the procedures uh what quite were
quite the right way
yeah he needs to accelerate it quickly
and we need to accelerate quickly to get
through all these with a half season to
go the best free agent acquisition has
been oh my gosh okay shout outs first
okay shout outs landon of course
phenomenal go ahead and take jamie
collins just pick one
smith is my one for the green bay
packers he's been amazing i mean yes
seven sacks he's changed the attitude of
that team he's the best player on that
defense right now they move them all
around the defensive front i mean that
was a great job by him i hope you heard
all my other shout outs it was fowler
jamie collins landon collins but zadaria
smith is the one i'm going with mike
florio up yours on a wednesday morning
i'm gonna go with a guy that probably
won't make it to the top of many lists
and again i'm going to
submit to recency bias how about tevin
coleman okay kevin coleman's averaging
4.7 yards per carry they only paid him
3.6 million for 2019. he had four
touchdowns on sunday and and he's
settling into that role that that kyle
shanahan envisioned for i mean there's
that connection back to atlanta and
shanahan felt strongly about him and
it's a shame that they gave up so much
to get jared mckinnon who will never
play for the 49ers by all appearances
but they're getting a hell of a return
on tevin coleman so dollar for dollar
without question it's kevin coleman yeah
he was on my list as well certainly uh
yeah he's been well you didn't give him
a shout out i didn't give him a shot he
wasn't shout out worthy but he's been
really good
all right blank has been the most
frustrating team to watch so far this
year well gosh there's a lot in this one
you know cleveland's in that
conversation the eagles a little bit but
they had injuries so i'm not going to
put this is actually easy it's the
chicago bears they're the most
frustrating team i've seen uh the
offense stinks naggy stinks as a play
caller trubisky stinks as a quarterback
they got no run game you know the
defense has led up some touchdowns and
scores and some big moments and they're
still really good but they get worn out
because the offense is off the field
every third place so they're back out
there it doesn't matter so they're the
most frustrating team i've seen this
year
yeah i i will agree with you but in the
interest of having some variety i'm
gonna say the chiefs just because that
defense is no better than it was last
year right they stepped up for the one
game on the thursday night against a
horrendous broncos offense gee what a
shock who isn't going to play great
defense against the broncos offense but
they got gashed again on sunday night
look now look
the game was closer than it could have
been without patrick mahomes playing but
that defense really is no better and
that's what's frustrating the offense is
still great and they still scored 24
points without mahomes but defensively
they're not doing nearly enough remember
we said all they have to be is a little
bit better on defense than their super
bowl team well they haven't been any
better if anything they've been worse
especially against the run well i i i
hear you they're still frustrating there
i do i'm still feeling good though about
where it's going on the defense uh mike
i watched that film and you know i talk
about it on my podcast from monday
because i let the fans vote and the fans
wanted to know what happened in kansas
city green bay i'm just saying the
defense played good that night too if it
is number 12 is not at quarterback or if
it's not russell wilson or deshawn
watson or something like that you know i
don't know they wouldn't have lost that
game i mean 12 won that game with some
of his you know magic uh really so i do
like where it's going they've changed
their formula and that's positive it's
still not a great defense i'm here i
hear you that's frustrating but i do
think the last two weeks have given me
some hope that it could get better
all right last one after what we've seen
so far this year
blank has earned the right to be a
starting quarterback somewhere in 2020.
well i mean the obvious answer there is
teddy bridgewater uh i i look at him and
then you know gardner minchu but i'll
say teddy bridgewater just to just to
you know lead it off and make it one guy
here yeah i mean bridgewater came in in
a very tough situation where you got to
fill the shoes of drew brees the team
expects to win oh they were 1-1 because
they lost to the rams he didn't look
good when he came in for
drew brees in that rams game but you
know slowly but surely played good
football and i do think he's earned the
right to at least compete for a job you
know he's he's never gonna be a guy or
at least at this point right now where
i'm gonna go oh he's one of the 20 best
quarterbacks in football no i think he's
a low end starter really great backup
but i do think what he showed us is that
he deserves to at least be in that
starting conversation
i got to go with the other guy you
mentioned in gardner minshew and i think
he will be the jaguars starting
quarterback next year and you know for
all the money that they paid to blake
bortles and then cut him after one
season and then they sign nick foles at
22 million dollars per year on a fairly
short term deal they're just gonna have
to bite the bullet because i think
minshu has the upside then maybe foles
doesn't this really is a heck of a
problem for the jaguars i mean we look
at the saints situation with drew brees
and teddy bridgewater we knew it was
going to be drew brees when he was
healthy with the panthers we yeah i
guess we assume if and when cam newton's
healthy he'll go back i mean a healthy
cam newton is better than kyle allen
with nick falls i don't know what you do
and i don't think the jaguars know what
to do they can't get they're trying not
to think about it yeah they can't get
out i mean
maybe they trade them i don't know but
they can't get out this year they're
going to get killed i mean you know it's
they'll be 33 million dollars in dead
cap i don't you can't do that so
uh i'm with you it's a very interesting
situation because minchu has done more
than just be your normal backup
quarterback coming in like we saw last
week i mean you and i were watching that
game he made some plays where we were
like whoa like that's legit way to like
extend the play or great throw so
i'm with you there he's he's certainly
proved himself and been a lot better
than i gave him credit for
yeah and that's the thing there hasn't
been a player that has excited the fan
base in jacksonville in a long time and
and gardner minshew has done that and
there's a business component to this
sport when looking you know look at the
shots in jacksonville if you're watching
on tv there's actually people yeah well
that's carolina there but before that
was jacksonville there's people at the
games people are excited in jacksonville
and there's something to be said for
that i feel bad for nick foles but uh i
think after this year there may be
serious consideration given to moving
foals and making minshew the guy and he
has proven that he deserves it and
inevitably i think he'll be the starter
in jacksonville it's just whether it's
next year or the year after
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports